hi I want to talk to you about thinking
your way through the vaping epidemic
ever since
actually it was kind of right around the
time I released a video a mini
documentary about vaping people started
reporting pulmonary illnesses plaguing
the country that had become an epidemic
their 450 cases 5 people dead and
they're all linked to vaping right so
everyone's in a panic and everyone's
wondering should I stop taping you know
should should I tell my friends to stop
vaping what's going on here what the
hell is happening is my watermelon candy
you know killing me is my bubblegum pop
gonna suddenly pop my lungs no but we'll
get into why I say that and to start
let's just start by understanding that
when we say vaping related illnesses
that's much like saying drinking related
illnesses it doesn't specify anything to
what is being drank right just like
there are all different types of
beverages there are all different types
of vape juices and what is in them some
are quality controlled like Red Bull and
some are not like maybe your friends
homemade beer or whatever so with that
understood let's talk about first about
the reactions the the dumbest one and
the one that people are citing and that
is causing hysteria is the CDC who has
said just stop vaping all together just
don't vape at all until we figure out
what the what is going on you know it's
very sort of a trump response total and
complete shutdown until our country's
representatives can figure out what the
hell is going on the problem with that
is that we sort of do know what's going
on but maybe just the CDC doesn't know
what's going on so let me explain within
any uncertain event there are always
likelihoods associated to those
certainties let me give you an example
so let's say my remote I can't find my
remote control for my TV there are a lot
of explanations not all of them are
equally true it would be really dumb to
call the police and say hey I think
someone has moved
remote that could be true but it's
probably true that I or my wife moved it
and didn't realize it and so we need to
think in the same way about the vaping
epidemic vaping has been done for years
with no acute pulmonary problems so is
it likely that it is the established
vape juice brands that have been around
forever that you could maybe equate to
like Red Bull they've been doing it
awhile nobody's caught nobody's died or
is it the black market
THC juice that has been going around
being passed to the kiddos you know it's
probably that probably the black market
no quality control product that is being
that is causing all the issues so that's
pretty much it that's kind of the
explanation I know that's kind of boring
I know that's not too exciting to hear
that it's that it's not your watermelon
candy vape juice that's been sold in
your vape shop it's probably the
cannabis oil that is a you know sold
behind the back of the exon I'm sorry to
tell you that but it it just what gets
me is that there's such a loop I don't
know ISM within public health that
border lines on the irresponsible
because in the same way that it's super
irresponsible to say that you know what
the cause of something is when you don't
it's equally irresponsible to say we
just don't know anything when you do
know something we do know that most of
the cases have been linked to THC we
also know that people that especially
the black market THD industry is filled
with varieties of you know quality
control say food safety you know all
these things whereas we know that
they're very high in some of these under
other industries there's a lot of
respective ate brands that are actually
known for their quality so to say that
those are equal it's irresponsible both
to the consumer who now has to decide
well do I give up everything or do I
just not take any educated action and
it's also irresponsible to the vaping
industry who are doing their best to
regulate a product and create a sense of
trust and by doing this like oh we don't
know
you're freaking everyone out needlessly
should we still be open to the evidence
yes of course we should still be open to
the evidence but should we also tell
people what is the most likely thing yes
so CDC who is telling everyone to stop
making all together they take an al FDA
who is telling people the right thing
which is that hey you should probably
avoid THC vape oils while this is going
on they're doing the right thing that's
it
just a little please be saying think
about these hysterias when they happen
that's all I wanted to say
[Music]